yeah hello and welcome to this video
which is something completely out of the
ordinary but it's something important to
announce some chemicals maybe I can meet
you in London this week it's a little
bit of a spontaneous decision what what
I'm doing then only AM was organised in
the last couple of days that I'm going
to attend the event that you see right
here in the video there's an event in
London on Wednesday November 29 and when
this was created it was just an just an
evening of chess with I am John but
following you yeah you know his YouTube
channel very likely and yeah it was
decided later that I should come as well
so we will have an evening of chess with
with both of us this was um actually
organized by chasuble as you see on top
the chess of a website that I'm
cooperating with it has released two of
my repertoire the Benko and the English
repertoire and I really like working
with chasuble and John is a co-founder
so I'm happy to meet him and I know him
from a couple of years back when he
started out with his YouTube channel we
were discussing some things and we had
some matches there to get his channel
going and but now it is really really
popular so I'm happy to meet John for
the first time we've of course we've
been on skype and everything but it's
not the same thing as meeting somebody
in person yeah and if you are in London
or around the area maybe you can join as
well you can see him the the date it is
at 5:00 p.m. gmt london time and it's
it's in london at the better see Labor
Club here's the address and I'm also
going to put in a link in the
description of courses that you can go
there yeah what will happen at the event
it's early it's roughly like four hours
four and a half hours is the plan
time spent and I mean there will be
drinks and snacks available at the venue
and there will be some chests that will
very likely be your blitz tournament
that will be will be played and we're
not quite sure everything was very
spontaneous maybe John John and I also
play some sort of match will we'll see
we'll see what happens and what people
yeah like us to do or if there are many
questions maybe we don't we can get
there so we will see what happens so if
you are in London at that at that time
and I just like in two days or if you
live in London I mean it so it's a
pretty pretty big city so if you can
make it would be happy to join you there
and have a chat about chess or whatever
you you'd like to talk about so um yeah
take note if you can make it I would be
very happy to meet you there yeah okay
bye bye and maybe see you in London in
two days